There was one very important thing that
had happened to me when I was 16 years
old.
Even though I was almost an
unpopular kid in my school.
They voted me for two years in a row,
the chairman of the programming committee,
which means I ran student assemblies
five days a week and I program to a week.
Um,
so I was the emcee for these things.
And one day that you,
did you manage that and
simultaneously be unpopular?
Uh,
that's a good question.
I think my school had verily very,
my stool was school,
was founded by an Acolyte of John
Dewey and he was behind the scenes are
actually setting the school up and it,
you know,
schools have their popularity positions,
president,
vice president,
secretary,
treasurer,
all of that.
But my school was clever enough to start
putting functional teams committees
together in your very
first days at school,
your very first days
of your freshman year.
Now when you,
when you have kids vote for president and
vice president the garden and vote for
the most popular kid in the
school as the precedent,
the second most popular kid,
his vice president,
the most popular girl as secretary,
and the most popular Jewish treasurer.
That's just the way it goes.
Um,
so I was never a line for
any of those positions.
I had no popularity whatsoever.
In fact,
one of my classmates actually fired with
remarkable accuracy from only 23 of the
way a soccer ball directly into my face.
And believe me,
it has a lot of force.
So 20 feet.
So,
but when it comes to functional positions,
like how do we run
these school assemblies?
The popular kids don't have a clue.
So if you bring them into a room,
if there arbitrarily,
for example,
assigned to a committee,
um,
they will all piss on their
little piece of territory.
They'll all stake out a position of some
kind just to establish their status in
the room.
And after 15 minutes of this,
when they've all said their piece and
it comes time to actually do something,
they're clueless.
They're silent,
they don't know what to do.
And if there's an unpopular geek like me,
who at that 20 minute mark
all of a sudden has an idea,
they will glom around you
even if they don't like you.
Right.
So,
so,
so yeah,
so competence can,
can,
can step in where we're
popularity cannot go.
Yes,
you've got,
that's a very well put fray.
So,
so there I was the head of this
programming committee and one of the,
it became,
one of the juniors came to me and said,
we're doing a dance.
We're,
you know,
we're setting up a dance and
could you advertise it for us?
And he didn't realize just
how absurd that statement was.
If there's a dance or a
party of any kind in buffalo,
New York,
one of the first things you have to
realize about it is I am not just
disinvited.
I haven't decided to stay as
far away as humanly possible.
And yet they want me to
advertise this dance.
So Jordan,
I can't dance.
I am,
I can't do a box.
I can't do a Fox trot.
I can't do a waltz.
I can't do any of those things,
but I went on stage and put some music
on the turn table and danced and I saw
the pupils dilating of the audience,
350 people who hated me and hated
me for two and a half years.
At that point,
their pupils were dilating,
their faces were melting.
I felt that pseudopod at the energy
coming to me and through me as if I were a
pipe.
I felt it going up to something
inside of me more or less,
that had level that
utterly transmogrified it.
And I felt the energy being sent back
through every Lou that I was making and I
had an out of body experience.
I saw,
I thought I was on the ceiling.
I watched all of this from the ceiling
and apparently it looked like a loony
toon drawn on Lsd
as if Chuck Jones had been doing Tom
and Jerry after taking a very big hit of
acid.
It was one of the strangest,
weirdest things you've ever
seen and when it was all over.
So that was my ecstatic experience.
When it was all over,
the audience did something.
It had never done in my days,
so that school and would never do again.
So long as I was there,
it surged to the photo on the stage and
as if it had practiced this act all its
life,
it picked me up off the stage.
It put me on its shoulders,
it carried me out of the auditorium,
and it carried me up the pathway to the
building above where we had our classes.
So that was my introduction.
Yeah.
And,
but this is stats,
crazy story,
right.
And this is three years after I'd gone
off after the ecstatic experience,
knowing that it was something vital.
I mean,
I'd heard at the age of 14,
two years earlier,
I had heard that there was a book
called the varieties of the religious
experience.
And in those days we had no Amazon.
Um,
we had local bookstores and
local bookstores in Buffalo.
I mean,
give me a break.
Um,
but I finally found a copy at the
University of Buffalo Bookstore.
And it felt as if William James had been
laying out a series of examples of the
ecstatic experience,
um,
with all of its delusions
and hallucinations and all
the rest on the laboratory
bench.
And then saying to me,
look,
you're coming along,
70 years later you're going to have
scientific tools that I did not have.
This is your job.
And it was my job,
not just as William James
was giving it to me,
cause something deep inside of me
was crying out to understand it.
And it probably was that the
privilege of social disconnection,
the privilege of social
deprivation because that
privilege made me sensitive and
it's always made me
sensitive to group behavior.
So when I was in Moscow in 2005 lecturing
a group of quantum physicists from all
over the world,
and why everything that you know
about quantum physics does wrong.
It's because there is no such
thing as an isolated particle.
Every particle is part of our herd,
a mob,
a group of some kind.
Um,
the,
a lot of quantum physicists
based on the idea that when you,
when you treat a Photon,
a single photon in a certain way,
when you split it into
here's how it's going to be,
hey,
but if it's being measured,
that's not going to happen.
Well,
guess what?
We're constantly taking
each other's measure.
Photons are constantly taking each of
those measure because they move in groups,
crowds and herds.
That's why I beam of sunshine
comes through your window,
not a photon of sunshine.
And when I finished the speech,
I was sure they were going to throw me
out of the conference because these are
all people committed deeply.
It's a quantum physics.
And instead they sat there beaming like
proud uncles and I could not figure out
why.
And three years later,
my collaborator in quantum physics,
uh,
at the university,
at the college and the of log mathematics,
so the Russian Academy
of Sciences in Moscow,
an email and he said,
doctor,
um,
use your cough.
Who ran that conference and gave you such
a hard time about your credit card has
just published a book.
It's a new approach to quantum physics.
It's called constructive physics.
You have to get it immediately.
So I downloaded it from arcs of org.
I listened to it that afternoon on my
hour and a half walk through the park on
my way to the cafe where I do all
my work and I got all excited.
Every social concept.
That means every concept that I had
given in this talk was in this book.
So Jordan,
I've had the privilege of proceedings
through life with this enormous advantage.
Social deprivation.